la guerre est revenu tout le continent
européen
et l'union européenne s'est montrée à la
hauteur de de l'histoire en adoptant les
sanctions les plus importantes de son
histoire c'est des sanctions très rapide
qui ont été adoptés est très lourde tu
veux qu'ils ont un parc déjà en de
manière très important de l'économie
russe entre l'union européenne et un
scooter d'accueil donc elle a accueilli
cce craignant qu'ils fuient et elle est
là elle aura offert protection
nous avons vu une accélération de
l'europe de la défense en six jours il a
eu plus de progrès en vente en europe de
la défense nous avons décidé pour la
première fois d'investir
dans des armes létales donc 500 millions
d'euros ont été
investis pour livrer des armes létales à
l'armée craignant pour lui permettre de
se battre
aujourd'hui l'union européenne est
dépendante à 40% des importations de gaz
russe à l'union européenne présenté hier
un plan pour réduire
cette dépendance très très rapidement en
renforçant si à la production du biogaz
dans l'union européenne ou qu'on propose
de doubler la production de gaz dans
l'union européenne et en faisant un
effort sans précédent pour renforcer
l'efficacité énergétique donc mieux
isoler le bâtiment
[Musique]